OK, good morning.
So today, we're going to
continue our exploration of
multithreaded algorithms.
Last time we talked about some
aspects of scheduling,
and a little bit about
linguistics to describe a
multithreaded competition.
And today, we're going to
actually deal with some
algorithms.
So, we're going to start out
with a really simple,
actually, what's fun about
this, actually,
is that everything I'm going to
teach you today I could have
taught you in week two,
OK, because basically it's just
taking the divide and conquer
hammer, and just smashing
problem after problem with it.
OK, and so, actually next
week's lectures on caching,
also very similar.
So, everybody should bone up on
their master theorem and
substitution methods for
occurrences, and so forth
because that's our going to be
doing.
And of course,
all the stuff will be on the
final.
So let's start with matrix
multiplication.
And we'll do n by n.
So, our problem is to do C
equals A times B.
And the way we'll do that is
using divide and conquer,
as we saw before,
although we're not going to use
Strassen's method.
OK, we'll just use the ordinary
thing, and I'll leave Strassen's
as an exercise.
So, the idea is we're going to
look at matrix multiplication in
terms of an n by n matrix,
in terms of n over 2 by n over
2 matrices.
So, I partition C into four
blocks, and likewise with A and
B.
OK, and we multiply those out,
and that gives us the
following.
Make sure I get all my indices
right.
OK, so it gives us the sum of
these two n by n matrices.
OK, so for example,
if I multiply the first row by
the first column,
I'm putting the first term,
A_1-1 times B_1-1 in this
matrix, in the second one,
A_1-2 times B_2-1 gets placed
here.
So, when I sum them,
and so forth,
for the other entries,
and when I sum them,
I'm going to get my result.
So, we can write that out as a,
let's see, I'm not sure this is
going to all fit on one board,
but we'll see we can do.
OK, so we can write that out as
a multithreaded program.
So this, we're going to see
that n is an exact power of two
for simplicity.
And since we're going to have
two matrices that we have to
add, we're going to basically
put one of them in our output,
C; that'll be the first one,
and we're going to use a
temporary matrix,
T, which is also n by n.
OK, and the code looks
something like this,
OK, n equals one,
and C of one gets A of 1-1
times B of 1-1.
Otherwise, what we do then is
we partition the matrices.
OK, so we partition them into
the block.
So, how long does it take me to
partition at matrix into blocks
if I'm clever at my programming?
Yeah?
No time, or it actually does
take a little bit of time.
Yeah, order one,
basically, OK,
because all it is is just index
calculations.
You have to change what the
index is.
You have to pass in what you're
passing these in addition to A,
B, and C for example,
pass and arrange which would
have essentially a constant
overhead.
But it's basically order one
time.
Basically order one time,
OK, to partition the matrices
because all we are doing is
index calculations.
And all we have to do is just
as we go through,
is just make sure we keep track
of the indices,
OK?
Any questions about that?
People follow?
OK, that's sort of standard
programming.
So then, what I do is I spawn
multiplication of,
woops, the sub-matrices,
and spawn --
-- and continue,
C_2-1, gets A_2-1,
B_1-1, two, and let's see,
2-2, yeah, it's 2-1.
OK, and continuing onto the
next page.
Let me just make sure I somehow
get the indentation right.
This is my level of
indentation, and I'm continuing
right along.
And now what I do is put the
results in T,
and then --
OK, so I've spawn off all these
multiplications.
So that means when I spawn,
I get to, after I spawn
something I can go onto the next
statement, and execute that even
as this is executing.
OK, so that's our notion of
multithreaded programming.
I spawn off these eight things.
What do I do next?
What's the next step in this
code?
Sync.
Yeah.
OK, I've got to wait for them
to be done before I can use
their results.
OK, so I put a sync in,
say wait for all those things I
spawned off to be done,
and then what?
Yeah.
That you have to add T and C.
So let's do that with a
subroutine call.
OK, and then we are done.
We do a return at the end.
OK, so let's write the code for
add, because add,
we also would like to do in
parallel if we can.
And what we are doing here is
doing C gets C plus T,
OK?
So, we're going to add T into
C.
So, we have some code here to
do our base case,
and partitioning because we're
going to do it divide and
conquer as before.
And this one's actually a lot
easier.
We just spawn,
add a C_1-1,
T_1-1, n over 2,
C_1-2, T_1-2,
n over 2, C_2-1,
T_2-1, n over 2,
C_2-2, 2-2-2,
n over 2, and then sync,
and return the result.
OK, so all we're doing here is
just dividing it into four
pieces, spawning them off.
That's it.
OK, wait until they're all
done, then we return with the
result.
OK, so any questions about how
this code works?
So, remember that,
here, we're going to have a
scheduler underneath which is
scheduling this onto our
processors.
And we're going to have to
worry about how well that
scheduler is doing.
And, from last time,
we learned that there were two
important measures,
OK, that can be used
essentially to predict the
performance on any number of
processors.
And what are those two
measures?
Yeah, T_1 and T infinity so
that we had some names.
T_1 is the work,
good, and T infinity is
critical path length,
good.
So, you have to work in the
critical path length.
If we know the work in the
critical path length,
we can do things like say what
the parallelism is of our
program, and from that,
understand how many processors
it makes sense to run this
program on.
OK, so let's do that analysis.
OK, so let's let M_P of n be
the p processor execution time
for our mult code,
and A_P of n be the same thing
for our matrix addition code.
So, the first thing we're going
to analyze is work.
And, what do we hope our answer
to our work is?
What we analyze work,
what do we hope it's going to
be?
Well, we hope it's going to be
small.
I'll grant you that.
What could we benchmark it
against?
Yeah, if we wrote just
something that didn't used to
have any parallelism.
We'd like our parallel code
when run on one processor to be
just as fast as our serial code,
the normal code that we would
use to write to do this problem.
That's generally the way that
we would like these things to
operate, OK?
So, what is that for matrix
multiplication in the naÔve way?
Yeah, it's n^3.
Of course, we use Strassen's
algorithm, or one of the other,
faster algorithms beat n^3.
But, for this problem,
we are just going to focus on
n^3.
I'm going to let you do the
Strassen as an exercise.
So, let's analyze the work.
OK, since we have a subroutine
for add that we are using in the
multiply code,
OK, we start by analyzing the
add.
So, we have A_1 of n,
OK, is, well,
can somebody give me a
recurrence here?
What's the recurrence for
understanding the running time
of this code?
OK, this is basically week two.
This is lecture one actually.
This is like lecture two or,
at worst, lecture three.
Well, A of 1 of n.
Plus order one,
right.
OK, that's right.
So, we have four problems of
size n over 2 that we are
solving.
OK, so to see this,
you don't even have to know
that we are doing this in
parallel, because the work is
basically what would happen if
it executed on a serial machine.
So, we have four problems of
size n over 2 plus order one is
the total work.
Any questions about how I got
that recurrence?
Is that pretty straightforward?
If not, let me know.
OK, and so, what's the solution
to this recurrence?
Yeah, order n^2.
How do we know that?
Yeah, master method,
so n to the log base two of
four, right, is n^2.
Compare that with order one.
This dramatically dominates.
So this is the answer,
the n to the log base two of
four, n^2.
OK, everybody remember that?
OK, so I want people to bone up
because this is going to be
recurrences, and divide and
conquer and stuff is going to be
on the final,
OK, even though we haven't seen
it in many moons.
OK, so that's good.
That's the same as the serial.
If I had to add 2N by n
matrices, how long does it take
me to do it?
n^2 time.
OK, so the input is size n^2.
So, you're not going to be the
size of the input if you have to
look at every piece of the
input.
OK, let's now do the work of
the matrix multiplication.
So once again,
we want to get a recurrence
here.
So, what's our recurrence here?
Yeah?
Not quite.
Eight, right,
good.
OK, eight, M1,
n over 2, plus,
yeah, there's theta n^2 for the
addition, and then there's extra
theta one that we can absorb
into theta n^2.
Isn't asymptotics great?
OK, it's just great.
And so, what's the solution to
that one?
Theta n^3, why is that?
Man, we are exercising old
muscles.
Aren't we?
And they're just creaking.
I can hear them.
Why is that?
Yeah, master method because
we're looking at,
what are we comparing?
Yeah, n to the log base two of
eight, or n^3 versus n^2,
this one dominates order n^3.
OK, so this is same as serial.
This was the same as serial.
That's good.
OK, we know we have a program
that on one processor,
will execute the same as our
serial code on which it's based.
Namely, we could have done
this.
If I had just got rid of all
the spawns and syncs,
that would have just been a
perfectly good piece of
pseudocode describing the
runtime of the algorithm,
describing the serial
algorithm.
And its run time ends up being
exactly the same,
not too surprising.
OK?
OK, so now we do the new stuff,
critical path length.
OK, so here we have A infinity
of n.
Ooh, OK, so we're going to add
up the critical path of this
code here.
Hmm, how do I figure out the
critical path on a piece of code
like that?
So, it's going to expand into
one of those DAG's.
What's the DAG going to look
like?
How do I reason?
So, it's actually easier not to
think about the DAG,
but to simply think about
what's going on in the code.
Yeah?
Yeah, so it's basically,
since all four spawns are
spawning off the same thing,
and they're operating in
parallel, I could just look at
one.
Or in general,
if I spawned off several
things, I look at which everyone
is going to have the maximum
critical path for the things
that I've spawned off.
So, when we do work,
we're usually doing plus when I
have multiple subroutines.
When we do critical path,
I'm doing max.
It's going to be the max over
the critical paths of the
subroutines that I call.
OK, and here they are all
equal.
So what's the recurrence that I
get?
What's the recurrence I'm going
to get out of this one?
Yeah, A infinity,
n over 2, plus constant,
OK, because this is what the
worst is of any of those four
because they're all the same.
They're all a problem looking
at the critical path of
something that's half the size,
for a problem that's half the
size.
OK, people with me?
OK, so what's the solution to
this?
Yeah, that's theta log n.
That's just,
once again, master theorem,
case two, because the solution
to this is n to the log base two
of one, which is n to the zero.
So we have, on this side,
we have one,
and here, we're comparing it
with one.
They're the same,
so therefore we tack on that
extra log n.
OK, so tack on one log n.
OK, so case two of the master
method.
Pretty good.
OK, so that's pretty good,
because the critical path is
pretty short,
log n compared to the work,
n^2.
So, let's do,
then, this one which is a
little bit more interesting,
but not much harder.
How about this one?
What's the recurrence going to
be?
Critical path of the
multiplication?
So once again,
it's going to be the maximum of
everything we spawned off in
parallel, which is,
by symmetry,
the same as one of them.
So what do I get here?
M infinity, n over 2,
plus theta log n.
Where'd the theta log n come
from?
Yeah, from the addition.
That's the critical path of the
addition.
Now, why is it that the maximum
of that with all the spawns?
You said that when you spawn
things off, you're going to do
them, yeah, you sync first.
And, sync says you wait for all
those to be done.
So, you're only taking the
maximum, and across syncs you're
adding.
So, you add across syncs,
and across things that you
spawned off in parallel.
That's where you are doing the
max.
OK, but if you have a sync,
it says that that's the end.
You've got to wait for
everything there to end.
This isn't going on in parallel
with it.
This is going on after it.
So, whatever the critical path
is here, OK, if I have an
infinite number of processors,
I'd still have to wait up at
this point, and that would
therefore make it so that the
remaining execution gear was
whatever the critical,
I would have to add whatever
the critical path was to this
one.
Is that clear to everybody?
OK, so we get this recurrence.
And, that has solution what?
Yeah, theta log squared n.
OK, once again,
by master method,
case two, where this ends up
being a constant versus log n,
those don't differ by a
polynomial amount,
or equal to a log factor.
What we do in that circumstance
is tack on an extra log factor.
OK, so as I say,
good idea to review the master
method.
OK, that's great.
So now, let's take a look at
the parallelism that we get.
We'll just do it right here for
the multiplication.
OK, so parallelism is what for
the multiplication?
What's the formula for
parallelism?
So, we have p bar is the
notation we use for this
problem.
What's the parallelism going to
be?
What's the ratio I take?
Yeah, it's M_1 of n divided by
M infinity of n.
OK, and that's equal to,
that's n^3.
That's n^2, or log n^2,
sorry, log squared n.
OK, so this is the parallelism.
That says you could run up to
this many processors and expect
to be getting linear speed up.
If I ran with more processors
than the parallelism,
I don't expect to be getting
linear speed up anymore,
OK, because what I expect to
run in, is just time
proportional to critical path
length, and throwing more
processors at the problem is not
going to help me very much,
OK?
So let's just look at this just
to get a sense of what's going
on here.
Let's imagine that the
constants are irrelevant,
and we have,
say, thousand by thousand
matrices, OK,
so in that case,
our parallelism is 1,000^3
divided by log of 1,000^2.
What's log of 1,000?
Ten, approximately,
right?
Log base two of 1,000 is about
ten, so that's 10^2.
So, you have about 10^7
parallelism.
How big is 10^7?
Ten million processors.
OK, so who knows of a machine
with ten million processors?
What's the most number of
processors anybody knows about?
Yeah, not quite,
the IBM Blue Jean has a
humungous number of processors,
exceeding 10,000.
Yeah.
Those were one bit processors.
OK, so this is actually a
pretty big number,
and so, our parallelism is much
bigger than a typical,
actual number of processors.
So, we would expect to be able
to run this and get very good
performance, OK,
because we're never going to be
limited in this algorithm by
performance.
However, there are some tricks
we can do.
One of the things in this code
is that we actually have some
overhead that's not apparent
because I haven't run this code
with you, although I could,
which is that we have this
temporary matrix,
T, and if you look at the
execution stack,
we're always allocating T and
getting rid of it,
etc.
And, one of the things when you
actually look at the performance
of real code,
which is now that you have your
algorithmic background,
you're ready to go and do that
with some insight.
Of course, you're interested in
getting more than just
asymptotic behavior.
You're interested in getting
real performance behavior on
real things.
So, you do care about constants
in that nature.
OK, and one of the things is
having a large,
temporary variable.
That turns out to be a lot of
overhead.
And, in fact,
it's often the case when you're
looking at real code that if you
can optimize for space,
you also optimized for time.
If you can run your code with
smaller space,
you can actually run it with
smaller time,
tends to be a constant factor
advantage.
But, those constants can add
up, and can make a difference in
whether somebody else's code is
faster or your code is faster,
once you have your basic
algorithm.
So, the idea is to,
in this case,
we're going to get rid of it by
trading parallelism because
we've got oodles of parallelism
here for space efficiency.
OK, and the idea is we're going
to get rid of T.
OK, so let's throw this up.
So, who can suggest how I might
get rid of T here,
get rid of this temporary
matrix?
Yeah?
So, if you just did adding it
into C?
So, the issue that you get
there if they're both adding
into C is you get interference
between the two subcomputations.
Now, there are ways of doing
that that work out,
but you now have to worry about
things we're not going to talk
about such as mutual exclusion
to make sure that as you're
updating it, somebody else isn't
updating it, and you don't have
race conditions.
But you can actually do it in
this context with no race
conditions.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly, OK,
exactly.
So, the idea is spawn off four
of them.
OK, they all update their copy
of C, and then spawn off the
other four that add their values
in.
So, that is a piece of code
we'll call mult add.
And, it's actually going to do
C gets C plus A times B.
OK, so it's actually going to
add it in.
So, initially you'd have to
zero out C, but we can do that
with code very similar to the
addition code with order n^2
work, and order log n critical
path.
So that's not going to be a big
part of what we have to deal
with.
OK, so here's the code.
We basically,
once again, do the base and
partition which I'm not going to
write out the code for.
We spawn a mult add of C1-1,
A1-1, B1-1, n over 2,
and we do a few more of those
down to the fourth one.
And then we put in a sync.
And then we do the other four --
-- and then sync when we're
done with that.
OK, does everybody understand
that code?
See that it basically does the
same calculation.
We actually don't need to call
add anymore, because we are
doing that as part of the
multiply because we're adding it
in.
But we do have to initialize.
OK, we do have to initialize
the matrix in this case.
OK, so there is another phase.
So, people understand the
semantics of this code.
So let's analyze it.
OK, so what's the work of
multiply, add of n?
It's basically the same thing,
right?
It's order n^3 because the
serial code is almost the same
as the serial code up there,
OK, not quite,
OK, but you get essentially the
same recurrence except you don't
even have the add.
You just get the same
recurrence but with order one
here, oops, order one up here.
So, it's still got the order
n^3 solution.
OK, so that,
I think, is not too hard.
OK, so the critical path
length, so there,
let's write out,
so multiply,
add, of n, OK,
what's my recurrence for this
code?
Yeah, 2M infinity,
M over 2 [ost that,
so order one.
Plus order one,
yeah.
OK, so the point is that we're
going to have,
for the critical path,
we're going to spawn these four
off, and so I take the maximum
of whatever those is,
which since they're symmetric
is any one of them,
OK, and then I have to wait.
And then I do it again.
So, that sync,
once again, translates into,
in the analysis,
it translates into a plus of
the critical path,
which are the things I spawn
off in parallel,
I do the max.
OK, so people see that?
So, I get this recurrence,
2MA of n over 2 plus order one,
and what's the solution to
that?
OK, that's order n,
OK, because n to the log base
two of two is n,
and that's bigger than one so
we get order n.
OK, so the parallelism,
we have p bar is equal to MA
one of n over MA infinity of n
is equal to, in this case,
n^3 over n, or order n^2.
OK, so for 1,000 by 1,000
matrices, for example,
by the way, 1,000 by 1,000 is
considered a small matrix,
these days, because that's only
one million entries.
You can put that on your laptop
no sweat.
OK, so, but for 1,000 by 1,000
matrices, our parallelism is
about 10^6.
OK, so once again,
ample parallelism for anything
we would run it on today.
And as it turns out,
it's faster in practice --
-- because we have less space.
OK, so here's a game where,
so, often the game you'll see
in theory papers if you look at
research papers,
people are often striving to
get the most parallelism,
and that's a good game to play,
OK, but it's not necessarily
the only game.
Particularly,
if you have a lot of
parallelism, one of the things
that's very easy to do is to
retreat on the parallelism and
gain other aspects that you may
want in your code.
OK, and so this is a good
example of that.
In fact, and this is an
exercise, you can actually
achieve work n^3,
order n^3 work,
and a critical path of log n,
so even better than either of
these two algorithms in terms of
parallelism.
OK, so that gives you n^3 over
log n parallelism.
So, that's an exercise.
And then, the other exercise
that I mention that that's good
to do is parallel Strassen,
OK, doing the same thing with
Strassen, and analyze,
what's the working critical
path and parallelism of the
Strassen code?
OK, any questions about matrix
multiplication?
Yeah?
Yeah, so that would take,
that would add a log n to the
critical path,
which is nothing compared to
the n.
Excuse me?
Well, you got to make sure C is
zero to begin with.
OK, so you have to set all the
entries to zero,
and so that will take you n^2
work, which is nothing compared
to the n^3 work you're doing
here, and it will cost you log n
additional to the critical path,
which is nothing compared to
the order n that you're
spending.
Any other questions about
matrix multiplication?
OK, as they say,
this all goes back to week two,
or something,
in the class.
Did you have a comment?
Yes, you can.
OK, yes you can.
It's actually kind of
interesting to look at that.
Actually, we'll talk later.
We'll write a research paper
after the class is over,
OK, because there's actually
some interesting open questions
there.
OK, let's move on to something
that you thought you'd gotten
rid of weeks ago,
and that would be the topic of
sorting.
Back to sorting.
OK, so we want to parallel sort
now, OK?
Hugely important problem.
So, let's take a look at,
so if I think about algorithms
for sorting that sound easy to
parallelize, which ones sound
kind of easy to parallelize?
Quick sort, yeah,
that's a good one.
Yeah, quick sort is a pretty
good one to parallelize and
analyze.
But remember,
quick sort has a little bit
more complicated analysis than
some other sorts.
What's another one that looks
like it should be pretty easy to
parallelize?
Merge sort.
When did we teach merge sort?
Day one.
OK, so do merge sort because
it's just a little bit easier to
analyze.
OK, we could do the same thing
for quick sort.
Here's merge sort,
OK, and it's going to sort A of
p to r.
So, if p is less than r,
then we get the middle element,
and then we'll spawn off since
we have to, as you recall,
when you merge sort you first
recursively sort the two
sub-arrays.
There's no reason not to do
those parallel.
Let's just do them in parallel.
Let's spawn off,
merge sort of A,
p, q, and spawn off,
then, merge sort of A,
q plus one r.
And then, we wait for them to
be done.
Don't forget your syncs.
Sync or swim.
OK, and then what to do what we
are done with this?
OK, we merge.
OK, so we merge of A,
p, q, r, which is merge A of p
up to q with A of q plus one up
to r.
And, once we've merged,
we're done.
OK, so this is the same code as
we saw before in day one except
we've got a couple of spawns in
the sync.
So let's analyze this.
So, the work is called T_1 of
n, what's the recurrence for
this?
This really is going back to
day one, right?
We actually did this on day
one.
OK, so what's the recurrence?
2T1 of n over 2 plus order n
merges order n time operation,
OK?
And so, that gives us a
solution of n log n,
OK, even if you didn't know the
solution, you should know the
answer, OK, which is the same as
the serial code,
not surprisingly.
That's what we want.
OK, critical path length,
AT infinity of n is equal to,
OK, T infinity of n over 2 plus
order n again.
And that's equal to order n,
OK?
So, the parallelism is then p
bar equals T_1 of n over T
infinity of n is equal to theta
of log n.
Is that a lot of parallelism?
No, we have a technical name
for that.
We call it puny.
OK, that's puny parallelism.
Log n?
Now, so this is actually
probably a decent algorithm for
some of the small scale
processors, especially the
multicore processors that are
coming on the market,
and some of the smaller SMP,
symmetric multiprocessors,
that are available.
You know, they have four or
eight processors or something.
It might be OK.
There's not a lot of
parallelism.
For a million elements,
log n is about 20.
OK, and so and then there's
constant overheads,
etc.
This is not very much
parallelism at all.
Question?
Yeah, so how can we do better?
I mean, it's like,
man, at merge,
right, it takes order n.
if I want to do better,
what should I do?
Yeah?
Sort in-place,
but for example if you do quick
sort and partition,
you still have a linear time
partition.
So you're going to be very much
in the same situation.
But what can I do here?
Parallel merge.
OK, let's make merge go in
parallel.
That's where all the critical
path is.
Let's figure out a way of
building a merge program that
has a very short critical path.
You have to parallelize the
merge.
This is great.
It's so nice to see at the end
of a course like this that
people have the intuition that,
oh, you can look at it and sort
of see, where should you put in
your work?
OK, the one thing about
algorithms is it doesn't stop
you from having to engineer a
program when you code it.
There's a lot more to coding a
program well than just having
the algorithm as we talked
about, also, in day one.
There's things like making it
modular, and making it
maintainable,
and a whole bunch of things
like that.
But one of the things that
algorithms does is it tells you,
where should you focus your
work?
OK, there's no point in,
for example,
sort of saying,
OK, let me spawn off four of
these things of size n over 4 in
hopes of getting,
I mean, it's like,
that's not where you put the
work.
You put the work in merge
because that's the one that's
the bottleneck,
OK?
And, that's the nice thing
about algorithms is it very
quickly lets you hone in on
where you should put your
effort, OK, when you're doing
algorithmic design in
engineering practice.
So you must parallelize the
merge.
The merge we're taking,
so here's the basic idea we're
going to use.
So, in general,
when we merge,
when we do our recursive merge,
we're going to have two arrays.
Let's call them A and B.
I called them A there.
I probably shouldn't have used
A.
I probably should have called
them something else,
but that's what my notes have,
so we're going to stick to it.
But we get a little bit more
space there and see what's going
on.
We have two arrays.
I'll call them A and B,
OK?
And, what we're going to do,
these are going to be already
sorted.
And our job is going to be to
merge them together.
So, what I'll do is I'll take
the middle element of A.
So this, let's say,
goes from one to l,
and this goes from one to m.
OK, I'll take the middle
element, the element at l over
2, say, and what I'll do is use
binary search to figure out,
where does it go in the array
B?
Where does this element go?
It goes to some point here
where we have j here and j plus
one here.
So, we know,
since this is sorted,
that all these things are less
than or equal to A of l over 2,
and all these things are
greater than or equal to A of l
over 2.
And similarly,
since that element falls here,
all these are less than or
equal to A of l over 2.
And all these are going to be
less greater than or equal to
two.
OK, and so now what I can do is
once I figured out where this
goes, I can recursively merge
this array with this one,
and this one with this one,
and then if I can just
concatenate them altogether,
I've got my merged array.
OK, so let's write that code.
Everybody get the gist of
what's going on there,
how we're going to parallelize
the merge?
Of course, you can see,
it's going to get a little
messy because j could be
anywhere.
Secures my code,
parallel merge of,
and we're going to put it in C
of one to n, so I'm going to
have n elements.
So, this is doing merge A and B
into C, and n is equal to l plus
n.
OK, so we're going to take two
arrays and merge it into the
third array, OK?
So, without loss of generality,
I'm going to say,
let's see, without loss of
generality, I'm going to say l
is bigger than m as I show here
because if it's not,
what do I do?
Just do it the other way
around, right?
So, I figure out which one was
bigger.
So that only cost me order one
to test that,
or whatever.
And then, I basically do a base
case, you know,
if the two arrays are empty or
whatever, what you do in
practice, of course,
is if they're small enough,
you just do a serial merge,
OK, if they're small enough,
and I don't really expect to
get much parallelism.
There isn't much work there.
You might as well just do
serial merge,
and be a little bit more
efficient, OK?
So, do the base case.
So then, what I do is I find
the j such that B of j is less
than or equal to A of l over 2,
less than or equal to B of j
plus one, using binary search.
What did recover binary search?
Oh yeah, that was week one,
right?
That was first recitation or
something.
Yeah, it's amazing.
OK, and now,
what we do is we spawn off p
merge of A of one,
l over 2, B of one to j,
and stick it into C of one,
two, l over 2 plus j.
OK, and similarly now,
we can spawn off a merge of A
of l over 2 plus one up to l.
B of j plus one up to M,
and a C of l over two plus j
plus one up to n.
And then, I sync.
So, code is pretty
straightforward,
doing exactly what I said we
were going to do over here,
analysis, a little messier,
a little messier.
So, let's just try to
understand us before we do the
analysis.
Why is it that I want to pick
the middle of the big array
rather than the small array?
What sort of my rationale
there?
That's actually a key part,
going to be a key part of the
analysis.
Yeah?
OK.
Yeah, imagine that B,
for example,
had only one element in it,
OK, or just a few elements,
then finding it in A might mean
finding it right near the
beginning of A.
And now, I'd be left with
subproblems that were very big,
whereas here,
as you're pointing out,
if I start here,
if my total number of elements
is n, what's the smallest that
one of these recursions could
be?
n over 4 is the smallest it
could be, OK,
because I would have at least a
quarter of the total number of
elements to the left here or to
the right here.
If I do it the other way
around, my recursion,
I might get a recursion that
was nearly as big as n,
and that's sort of,
once again, sort of like the
difference when we were
analyzing quick sort with
whether we got a good
partitioning element or not.
The partitioning element is
somewhere in the middle,
we're really good,
but it's always at one end,
it's no better than insertion
sort.
You want to cut off at least a
constant fraction in your
divided and conquered in order
to get the logarithmic behavior.
OK, so we'll see that in the
analysis.
But the key thing here is that
what we are going to do the
recursion, we're going to have
at least n over 4 elements in
whatever the smaller thing is.
OK, but let's start.
It turns out the work is the
hard part of this.
Let's start with critical path
length.
OK, look at that,
critical path length.
OK, so parallel merge,
so infinity of n is going to
be, at most, so if the smaller
piece has at least a quarter,
what's the larger piece going
to be of these two things here?
So, we have two problems
responding off.
Now, we really have to do max
because they're not symmetric.
Which one's going to be worse?
One could have,
at most, three quarters,
OK, of n.
Woops, 3n, of 3n over 4 plus,
OK, so the worst of those two
is going to be three quarters of
the elements plus,
what?
Plus log n.
What's the log n?
The binary search.
OK, and that gives me a
solution of, this ends up being
n to the, what?
n to the zero,
right.
OK, it's n to the log base four
thirds of one.
OK, it was the log of anything
of one is zero.
So, it's n to the zero.
So that's just one compared
with log n, tack on this log
squared n.
So, we have a critical path of
log squared n.
That's good news.
Now, let's hope that we didn't
blow up the work by a
substantial amount.
OK, so the work is PM_1 of n is
equal to, OK,
so we don't know what the split
is.
So let's call it alpha.
OK, so alpha n in one side,
and then the work on the other
side will be PM of one of one
minus alpha n plus,
and then still order of log n
to the binary search where,
as we've said,
alpha is going to fall between
one quarter and three quarters.
OK, how do we solve a
recurrence like this?
What's the technical name for
this kind of recurrence?
Hairy.
It's a hairy recurrence.
How do we solve hairy
recurrences?
Substitution.
OK, good.
OK, so we're going to say PM
one of k is less than or equal
to, OK, I want to make a good
guess here, OK,
because I've fooled around with
it.
I want it to be linear,
so it's going to have a linear
term, a times k minus,
and then I'm going to do b log
k.
So, this is this trick of
subtracting a low order term.
Remember that in substitution
in order to make it stronger?
If I just did ak it's not going
to work because here I would get
n, and then when I did this
substitution I'm going to get a
alpha n, and then a one minus
alpha n, and those two together
are already going to add up to
everything here.
So, there's no way I'm going to
get it down when I add this term
in.
So, I need to subtract
something from both of these so
as to absorb this term,
OK?
So, I'm skipping over those
steps, OK, because we did those
steps in lecture two or
something.
OK, so that's the thing I'm
going to guess where a and b are
greater than zero.
OK, so let's do the
substitution.
OK, so we have PM one of n is
less than or equal to,
OK, we substitute this
inductive hypothesis in for
these two guys.
So, we get a alpha n minus b
log of alpha n plus a of one
minus alpha n minus b log of one
minus alpha, maybe another
parentheses there,
one minus alpha n,
and even leave myself enough
space here plus a of one minus
alpha n minus b log of one minus
alpha, maybe another parenthesis
there, one minus alpha n.
I didn't even leave myself
enough space here.
Plus, let me just move this
over so I don't end up using too
much space.
So, b log of one minus alpha n
plus theta of log n.
How's that?
Are we OK on that?
OK, so that's just
substitution.
Let's do a little algebra.
That's equal to a of times
alpha na times one minus alpha
n.
That's just an,
OK, minus, well,
the b isn't quite so simple.
OK, so I have a b term.
Now I've got a whole bunch of
stuff there.
I've got log of alpha n.
I have, then,
this log of one minus alpha n,
OK, I'll start with the n,
and then plus theta log n.
Did I do that right?
Does that look OK?
OK, so look at that.
OK, so now let's just multiply
some of this stuff out.
So, I have an minus b times,
well, log of alpha n is just
log alpha plus log n.
And then I have plus log of one
minus alpha plus log n,
OK, plus theta log n.
That's just more algebra,
OK, using our rules for logs.
Now let me express this as my
solution minus my desired
solution minus a residual,
an minus b log n,
OK, minus, OK,
and so that was one of these b
log n's, right,
is here.
And the other one's going to
end up in here.
I have B times log n plus log
of alpha times one minus alpha
minus, oops, I've got too many.
Do I have the right number of
closes.
Close that, close that,
that's good,
minus theta log n.
Two there.
Boy, my writing is degrading.
OK, did I do that right?
Do I have the parentheses
right?
That matches,
that matches,
good.
And then B goes to that,
OK, good.
OK, and I claim that is less
than or equal to AN minus B log
n if we choose B large enough.
OK, this mess dominates this
because this is basically a log
n here, and this is essentially
a constant.
OK, so if I increase B,
OK, times log n,
I can overcome that log n,
whatever the constant is,
hidden by the asymptotic
notation, OK,
such that B times log n plus
log of alpha times one minus
alpha dominates the theta log n.
OK, and I can also choose my
base condition to be big enough
to handle the initial
conditions, whatever they might
be.
OK, so we'll choose A big
enough --
-- to satisfy the base of the
induction.
OK, so thus PM_1 of n is equal
to theta n, OK?
So I actually showed O,
and it turns out,
the lower bound that it is
omega n is more straightforward
because the recurrence is easier
because I can do the same
substitution.
I just don't have to subtract
off low order terms.
OK, so it's actually theta,
not just O.
OK, so that gives us a log,
what did we say the critical
path was?
The critical path is log
squared n for the parallel
merge.
So, let's do the analysis of
merge sort using this.
So, the work is,
as we know already,
T_1 of n is theta of n log n
because our work that we just
analyzed was order n,
same as for the serial
algorithm, OK?
The critical path length,
now, is T infinity of n is
equal to, OK,
so in normal merge sort,
we have a problem of half the
size, T of n over 2 plus,
now, my critical path for
merging is not order n as it was
before.
Instead, it's just over there.
Log squared n,
there we go.
OK, and so that gives us theta
of log cubed n.
So, our parallelism is then
theta of n over log cubed n.
And, in fact,
the best that's been done is,
sorry, log squared n,
you're right.
Log squared n because it's n
log n over log cubed n.
It's n over log squared n,
OK?
And the best,
so now I wonder if I have a
typo here.
I have that the best is,
p bar is theta of n over log n.
Is that right?
I think so.
Yeah, that's the best to date.
That's the best to date.
By Occoli, I believe,
is who did this.
OK, so you can actually get a
fairly good, but it turns out
sorting is a really tough
problem to parallelize to get
really good constants where you
want to make it so it's running
exactly the same.
Matrix multiplication,
you can make it run in parallel
and get straight,
hard rail, linear speed up with
a number of processors.
There is plenty of parallelism,
and running on more processors,
every processor carries a full
weight.
With sorting,
typically you lose,
I don't know,
20% in my experience,
OK, in terms of other stuff
going on because you have to
work really hard to get the
constants of this merge
algorithm down to the constants
of that normal merge,
right?
I mean that's a pretty good
algorithm, right,
the one that just goes,
BUZZING SOUND,
and just takes two lists and
merges them like that.
So, it's an interesting issue.
And a lot of people work very
hard on sorting,
because it's a hugely important
problem, and how it is that you
can actually get the constants
down while still guaranteeing
that it will scale up with a
number of processors.
OK, that's our little sojourn
into parallel land,
and next week we're going to
talk about caching,
which is another very important
area of algorithms,
and of programming in general.